we will never see the likes of Nelson
Mandela again but let me say to the
young people of Africa and the young
people around the world you too can make
his life work your own Madiba was
emerged as the last great liberator of
the 20th century like Gandhi he would
lead in the resistance movement like dr.
King he would give potent voice to the
claims of the impressed and the moral
necessity of racial justice emerging
from prison without the force of arms he
would like Abraham Lincoln hold his
country together when it threatened to
break apart and like America's Founding
Fathers he would erect a constitutional
order to preserve freedom from neutral
generations over 30 years ago while
still a student I learned of Nelson
Mandela and the struggles taking place
in this beautiful land and it stirred
something in me
it woke me up to my responsibilities to
others and to myself and it sent me on
an improbable journey that finds me here
today as he showed in painstaking
negotiations to transfer power and draft
new laws he was not afraid to compromise
for the sake of a larger goal and
because he was not only a leader of a
movement but a skillful politician the
Constitution that emerged was worthy of
this multiracial democracy true to his
vision of laws that protect minority as
well as majority rights and the precious
freedoms of every South Africa there are
too many people who happily embrace
Madiba's legacy of racial reconciliation
but passionately resist even modest
reforms that would challenge chronic
poverty and growing inequality there are
too many leaders who claim solidarity
with Madiba struggle for freedom but do
not tolerate dissent from their own
people
it's tempting I think to remember Nelson
Mandela at my [ __ ] smiling and serene
detached from the tawdry affairs of
lesser men but Madiba himself strongly
resisted such a lifeless portrait